hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on electron
fragmentation based workflows for
characterizing proteoforms with agilent
key tops
by joseph dr joseph beckman ceo of
omissions inc and dr rebecca glaskin
lcms application scientist from agilent
and joining us also will be cody
schwartzer a field system specialist
with agilent welcome to all three of you
i am susie valdez of labrutz and i will
be moderating today's event
welcome everyone we want to begin by
encouraging you to engage with us you
can submit as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box on the left and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that support tab found at the
top right or use that ask a question box
on the left
please join me now and welcoming all of
our presenters you may now begin your
presentation welcome to all of you
so today um cody myself is well
professor beckman i'm going to be
talking about the practical
electron-based fragmentation for
characterizing proteins
first i just like to show a comparison
of cid and ecb
and
first i'm going to start off with
traditional mass spectrometry just doing
the tandem aspect of cid
here you have collision induced
excitation
which you followed by unfolding and loss
of labile groups
leading a bond dissociation and your
fragment separation
with cid you can't get site localization
of where your labor modification are
cured
electron capture dissociation
starts by your radiating um your
biomolecule with low energy electrons
the initial electron capture followed by
charged neutralization and fragmentation
and they fragment separation
but you get able to retain your label
modification along the backbone are your
peptide fragments
now if we just look at a comparison of
the time scale and fragmentation
nomenclature of tandem msms techniques
you see civ is typically on the
microsecond activation time scale well
electron cache dissociation is about
10-15 10-16 seconds
there's a much faster
activation time
when we look on the right we can see the
difference in fragmentation nomenclature
so for cid you're typically getting your
bmi ions from cleavage of the amide
backbone
and then for ecd you're typically
generating you see the ion assignment
so
here it is showing a schematic of the
ecd cell
generated from the mission
and this can be incorporated into our
queuetalk family
and here we see the ecb cell attached to
a showing collision cell that can be
easily incorporated into our qtos
as shown here
with this ecd cell
installed in the instrumentation the
tuning is straightforward using a swarm
auto tuning that's included in mass
contract position software
you can still able to have the same
transmission as cid and resolution
as what you had originally before
installation of the ecd cell
the ext controller tracks the operation
of ms1 and ms2 operation of your
instrument
and with this ecd cell installed we have
multiple software workflows to get
better protein characterization
generating from bottom up to top down
analysis
with this cell installed you can also
use it for
coupling with lc on the front end of
your system as well as capillary
electrophoresis and our immobility
platform
so this is just showing how ecd cell
works you start with your
caustic science you have a charge
reduced species here in the yellow
spot where your electron cloud is then
you get your fragments generated out
from the output of your collision cell
and what this exc's measures advantage
over etd is that with the ecb cell well
peptides and proteins can be activated
to increase your side chain
fragmentation
with etd you typically have to cool your
protein molecules to mix with your anion
etd reagent
and this favors electron transfer but
not dissociation so it reduces
side chain fragmentation
and one of the challenges with ecd is
how do you confine these low energy
electrons
these low energy electrons tend to
strongly repel each other the emission
has figured this out by efficiently
using magnetic fields to restrain your
electrons into a type beam to fragment
your molecules passing through the
electron cloud
so you can see the electron cloud here
and yellow along this schematic picture
now you can see the flight path of using
liquid ions you have the
ions going in they get
enter the electron cloud and you
fragment the molecular ions so therefore
exit
how does this cxd work well it uses
magnetic fields to constrain the
electrons readily and use this dc static
fields to trap the electrons
accidentally
and here we have the time scale for the
exd cell it's typically again the
microsecond time scale
so you can see ext fragmentation is
complete by the time the peptides and
proteins fly through the ext cell about
five microseconds
and you can see that it couples really
nicely with these front-end separations
such as eye mobility capillary
electrophoresis or liquid chromatography
and can be easily incorporated into a
time-of-flight platform
so this is just showing some pictures of
what's used for tuning in of the ecd
cell
so first in this top upper left corner
we have the power supply that controls
the ecd cell
the exd control is underneath it this
window shows that you can tune it with
manual tuning the voltage is applied to
the lens elements in the magnet or you
can use an auto-tune feature that way
the ext controller can auto tune the
cell for you
there's also a nice visual voltage graph
in the upper right corner allows you to
look at the voltages applied to the ecd
cell
in the bottom right you see the filament
parameters this is where you control the
current applied to the filament of the
ecb cell
so now we're going to go into some data
so this is an example of some data we
collected on the 6560 in collaboration
with kathy gestel's lab at boston
university this is looking at the plus
three ions of substance p
and here we have our mass spectrum on
the upper
plot
a drift spectrum on the left and
abundance map in the middle
and we can see in the drift spectrum two
ions two structures a compact structure
an elongated structure
and if we look at the horizontal mass
spectrum for each of these conformers
you can see that by a cid by applying
tempo to the collision cell
we see a compact mass spectrum on top
and an elongated mass spectrum on top
and you can see through the cid spectrum
for each of these conformers and it's
pretty identical there's no
distinguishing features between these
two conformers
and we've got pretty good b y and
assignments across the peptide backbone
now if we form ecd on those two same
conformers as substance p
we have a compact ecb spectrum on top we
want to do the ecd spectrum on the
bottom
and two things we can easily notice
inside these highlighted red boxes are
the relative abundances of the c z ion
assignment
you can see the ratios of these c c ions
and these red boxes
vary depending on the compact birth
elongated structures
and you can see in the upper right
corner we still get really good sequence
coverage across the peptide backbone
next we wanted to look at the triptych
digest of nismab by acid and ecd so look
at site localization of glycopeptides to
see if you can retain the glycans with
on these peptides
and the upward plot is showing the tic
trace of the nist map tryptic digest
the bottoms are showing msm spectrum of
the following glycopeptides for gof
and we can see in the msms spectrum
we've seen the new namely
composition loss of the sugar moiety
from the glycogen structure really don't
see any print information regarding the
peptide backbone cleavages
now if you look at the same glycopeptide
ecd you see a lot of extensive
information within these plots
we see a lot of cesium assignments
as well as site localization of where
the glycogen is along the peptide
backbone and you see we've got good
sequence coverage across the peptide
backbone as well as site localization of
the glycan
you look at another example of the g1f
glycopeptide or the following
glycopeptide shown here
we have our tic on the top of the nysma
triptych digest
as well as the corresponding cid and sms
spectrum
and again the cid msns section shows
mainly
cleavage of the sugar moieties of the
glycogen structure attached to peptides
we really don't see much information in
regards to the peptide backbone
cleavages
now if we perform the same analysis as
ecd
we see a lot of incentive information
regarding peptide backbone cleavage with
the cz and ion and sinus
as well as site localization of the
glycan moiety is on the peptide backbone
so we can see from rebecca's example
here that these specs can really be
quite complex and we're going to be
relying really heavily on our data
analysis software in order to extract as
much information as possible and really
minimize that manual interpretation
before i begin my name is cody schwarzer
and i work with rebecca newmission to
help develop some of the data analysis
workflows that we'll be using for the
exd so
now today i'm going to be sharing uh
just one of our options
and this allows for our raw exd data to
be incorporated directly into your
protein metrics pipelines
protein metrics or bios
as many of you may already be aware as a
vendor neutral software
it's used by many of our customers
already for day-to-day cqa analysis
and agilent already has a relationship
with protein metrics as we use their hcp
tools as part of our own wholesale
protein workflow
what we're proposing here is that we
also incorporate ptm
to process our exv data
now the workflow is fairly
straightforward the data is
pre-processed using a tool called exd
process this has been developed by a
mission and joe will be going into some
further detail later on about his
specific capabilities but in this case
we can do things like
threshold centroid do some ms2 summing
if that's what you wish to do
and then when once we're finished we'll
export a dot mdml or a sums data mdml
file that can then just flow directly
into our bionic software
fortunately bionics pretty easy to use
interface and we don't need any
modification of the underlying software
in order to start processing those exe
files
so i have a quick video here just to
demonstrate uh how this would work if if
you're new to protein metrics
now you'll see it's fairly
straightforward we'll select our ms data
file
and define our fafsa file we can add
things like decoys and common
contaminants then we have our standard
matching parameters obviously in this
kcc and epd we can add in ptms and
glycons
that we might be interested in and
looking for can also select some fdr
cuts if we desire and then go ahead and
run that file now i have a pre-baked
result here and you can see this is a
bsa coverage
over on the left we have some nice
sequence coverage map
and
if i choose a particular pet side of
interest i can easily see all the
matches and the mass error associated
with those ms2 matches
now you can see they also have a ladder
and a pretty easy to find
table so you don't have to look that up
and now we can just zoom into individual
ions to validate those matches
what i really want to emphasize here is
this is an established software and it's
already a turnkey solution and we're not
really making any significant changes to
your existing cid workflows we don't
have to modify uh anything significantly
and we probably more importantly don't
have to retrain all of your end users on
a new software package
and so with that i'm going to hand it
over to joe beckman he's going to
discuss some more advanced options and
some kind of custom data analysis tools
that we can use
thanks rebecca and cody
we were really excited when we first
got a hold of agilent loaned us a
high-resolution q-top to try our cell in
and after installing it we were able to
get beautiful spectra of ubiquitin as
shown here
we were doing this from the six plus
charge state of ubiquinone which is
known to be tightly folded
and in a few seconds we could collect a
very complete spectrum
that would give on the order of 95 to 97
coverage from both
directions as shown here
and you can see even uh
in the enlargement on the bottom
that the small peaks that are very large
mass are still nicely resolved in the
qtox
but
we quickly realized that we were going
to be overwhelmed with information
because it was taking us hours
and annotate the spectrum
and so we started to look at different
programs and different ways but
analyzing it
one of the things when we first put this
into an analysis program that we
discovered was that we were missing a
couple of really important features
and these were sidechain fragmentations
that weren't normally aren't annotated
but because of the
enhanced ability to activate ions that
rebecca alluded to
you can see the loss of isopropyl groups
from leucine and ethyl groups from
lysine so we're able to
distinguish the isobaric leucine iso
leucine
couples by uh
by the side chain fragmentation
so
that's important because 16 of the human
proteome
is naturally
or consists of leucine and isoleucine so
it gives you even much more complete
information than you would get from etd
and other fragmentation methods
so we've spent quite a bit of time in
the past couple of years figuring out
how to
process the data that comes out of this
and as cody mentioned uh we've created a
program called exp process
that will both annotate the spectrum as
having been uh processed or collected
with ecd enabled
and outputted as some spectra in mcml
files that could be read by third-party
software
we've actually built this platform with
the idea that we can provide much more
complete software
and we're using an open source
set of programs that are
known as nine which is a data science
open source program developed in germany
and it's merged with openms which is
also a huge open source project
and it's described here in this project
or in this publication
so it's been under development for 17
years
and it has an enormous number of
functions that are really practical for
mass spec
and you can wire these together
by just connecting through a graphical
interface
different modules and functions that you
want to do so this
figure 2 was pretty intimidating
we're using a very basic one as shown in
the above
the figure above it and we're using an
open source program called msgf plus
but you can very simply change out ms
gf plus to mascot
and if you wanted to get false discovery
rates you can insert percolator which is
a very common
uh means of estimating false discovery
rates
and then we wrote a program that's
called exp viewer to be able to look at
the results and see what the spectra
look like
because it's always nice to see what
what data were you getting
now
the nice feature of nine is that you can
group all these functions together and
we can provide workflows
for lots of different applications
and you can create a library of these
that are essentially
transparent black boxes
so you don't have to be an expert you
don't have to know what's happening
underneath but as you use it you can
open it up
you can examine all these functions and
you can draw on a very flexible platform
to add more and more features
so this can grow with you um and it's
also something we're continuing to
develop
now to be able to look at the data
we created exp viewer
and this is displaying the data from
ubiquitin that i showed you in the first
plot
and what we've done here is generated a
fragmentation map that also is annotated
with the number of spectra that are
shown
so
if you start the blue dots
down here show you these c ions that are
generated and you can see they go all
the way through
with two notable gaps and these are
where prolines exist and because
of the proline side side chain being
cyclic
you don't get ecd fragmentation across
prolines
and if you look on the top uh panel
you're looking at the z ions coming from
the other direction
okay so you can easily
visualize the types of fragmentation
that are occurring
there's also some cid peaks in there and
there's fragmentation
that generates a ions that's also
present in the spectrum
the other thing we did is we added tilde
marks here
to indicate that you have side chain
fragmentation
now this is part of a program
or this program is in a set of features
that
lets you examine spectrum and i'm doing
this with a middle down workflow
so one of the things that i forgot to
mention is that
with ecd working with larger peptides
and in fact entire proteins is actually
better
because electron capture increases with
a square of charge
so long peptides and proteins fragment
even better
we're showing this with lyc digest
and here's a digest with sulfhydryls
reduced
and we're generating fragments that are
quite long and normally you wouldn't be
able to analyze with cid
and we're going to focus on the
glycosidic peptide which rebecca was
just showing you
being done with trips and digests here
we're working a much larger fragments
the workflow is basically run the digest
separated it collected the data run it
through msgf plus to identify peptides
and now we're viewing the results and
that's shown here
where the chromatogram is shown above
i put a blue
rectangle to show that this is where
the n glycoside peptide is eluting
this is the spectrum that's generated
and i've highlighted the peptide that
contains the enclosulated peptide
so if you click here this spectrum is
annotated
and then above it we can zoom and we can
see with a ruler of here's where the
glycan is
found between two of the fragments
let me uh
go to the next slide and show you
basically how this is working
so you can take your mouse and you can
click on the different dots and that
will show the spectrum so in this case
i'm going to start from the immunoside
one residue before the n glycan
and so you can see the c7 ion the c8
the c9
coming from the other side you can see
the spectrum
as you walk in uh so you're getting uh
identifications with fragments on both
sides
of the chain so you have a very high
degree of confidence of what this is
there's also a leucine uh present four
amino acids in from the carboxy terminus
and this is showing the spectrum that's
seen here so in this particular case
the side chain fragment is actually much
more dominant than the
main chain fragment the c4
and that has to do with the ions being
activated and the side chain
fragmentation coming apart
very quickly after the electron capture
event
so we're getting exceptional coverage of
side chain fragmentations that really
helps with identification
it's also very useful with side chain
fragmentation to note that
that breaks cysteine bonds
and here's an example of analyzing
insulin so this is
uh
insulin that's not reduced and it's
eluting off a standard hplc column
and you can see that you get very nice
fragments with ecd spectrum that are
nicely resolved
and if we start to analyze that what we
found was we could characterize where
all three disulfide bonds were located
and to illustrate this
we have to analyze it in six runs but
basically we compare we consider
breaking this bond
we look for the b chain
and we consider the a chain as a
post-translational modification
and we can get extensive fragmentation
across the b chain
repeat the analysis and you look for the
a chain with the b chain is modified
and so we've got very strong evidence
for this disulfide being present
and you repeat this process but we then
find evidence for all three disulfides
and how they were localized
this works on much larger proteins as
well
and here we're taking a nist antibody
and
basically what we're doing is breaking
the disulfide that holds the light chain
with the heavy chain
you can now see the light chain coming
off as a series of resolved residues
our result chains but you can figure out
the light mass
and then you can use the ecd peaks that
are located down here to start to
identify which light chains paired with
which heavy chain
or to start to study where
drug antibody conjugates might be
located
so in summary
the we have a very practical method of
doing electron fragmentation and now
we've developed a very flexible
set of workflows to analyze the data
that's coming
we get exceptional coverage with middle
down and top-down proteomics
we're able to
characterize disulfide bonds
and
ecd is ideal for measuring uh for
locating uh post-translational
modifications and the ability to do it
middle down means you can get
a lot more information about the co
local location of
phosphorylation events and other
post-translational modifications
you can look for artifacts
such as the formation of iso aspartate
from aspartate which i didn't show you
today but that works really well
uh and characterized
distinguished leucine from isoleucine
which rhizobaric
and there are a lot of other
capabilities that
for analyzing glycans
so finally um
we are very proud to be working with
agilent and their logo with trusted
answers
what i hope you can see from today is
with the fragmentation you can get
using our ecd cell
that you can get really even superior
answers or your your trusted answers are
enhanced considerably
because of the additional information
that you can get pretty easily so thank
you and we'll be happy to answer
questions
thank you dr beckman mr schwarzer for
that informative presentation
now we are now going to move to the q a
portion of our webinar and i want to
encourage all the participants to please
go ahead and ask questions by using that
ask a question box
so it looks like we already have some
great questions
coming in from our audience members
our first question
can you add the exd cell to an existing
q-top
so i'll go ahead and answer that
and the answer is yes that
we've designed this to be a replacement
for the standard collision cell it takes
about an hour not including pumping
venting and pumping down time to install
the cell
and then to uh bring the system back
together
so in fact we're selling this as an
add-on
even with new systems
thank you so much
and our next question can you still use
cid with the ex d cell instead installed
and does it still behave like a standard
qtof
and the answer is that yes you can use
it for standard cid spectra or
fragmentation
it still behaves and
gives what appears to be the same
fragmentation patterns
and you can combine ecd with cid
to get complementary information or to
help shake apart large molecules
and get much better coverage than it's
possible
um
in etd or with cid alone
thank you so much
our next question is there a simple way
to service or replace the ecd filament
right so the way that we produce
electrons is we have a hot filament that
sits in the middle of the ecd cell
much like a filament that happens in old
vacuum tubes
and we anticipate the lifetime is
between three to six months
but um to replace it now you have to
vent the instrument but there's a
trapdoor
that you can open up and you pull out
the um burnt out filament and plug in
the new one
and then restart the system
so it takes just a few minutes to pull
that off and the vacuum usually comes
back
in a couple of hours at
it's operational usually within an hour
thank you so much i want to give each of
you a little bit of an opportunity to
provide some closing remarks for our
audience members and again any questions
not asked today will be answered via
email from our presenters
we'll start with you dr beckman would
you like to provide any closing remarks
for our audience
yeah so it's been a lot of fun working
with ashland over the years and
particularly rebecca and cody as we
start to
turn the capabilities of the ecd cell
into actual workflows and solve real
problems
and we're really excited about the
results we're getting and the extension
that can happen
and we're looking forward to working
more with agilent to tackle more and
more problems
i think uh we saw earlier in john
valstad's presentation a really nice
example of what was done at the
university of michigan
for analyzing bsa with collision-induced
unfolding eye mobility and ecd
there are a lot more examples of
being able to solve the unsolvable now
oops i apologize and i also want to
offer you dr glasgon opportunity would
you like to provide any closing remarks
yes with the exd cell installed in our
qtop platforms it shows a nice
complementary technique to traditional
cid experiments for better
characterization of your biomolecules
thank you so much
and mr schwarzer are you able to
communicate with us
we weren't able to
have him log on and i'm so sorry to our
audience members but i know he
is appreciative of everyone
participating today again i want to
thank all three of you for your great
presentation and for your participation
today and i also want to give um another
opportunity for john who's joined us
today and he wanted to offer a few extra
comments to our participants john would
you like to add a couple of comments
i would thank you um actually these
workflows have been
just terrific and seeing the development
and the effort that's gone in from
emission working together
with uh our collaborators and especially
with rebecca and cody
now that these workflows are coming to
fruition agilent is actually initiating
a promotion in north america for end of
calendar year so contact your local mass
spec product specialist as there is a
very aggressive promotion in place
for adding an ext to an agilent qtop if
you're looking at end of year
situations so this will be good through
the calendar year thank you
and thank you so much and as a reminder
again to our audience any questions that
were not answered today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed via the email you
provided at the time of registration and
i want to thank our speakers again for
their time and for those of you who
participated and we hope all of you will
check out the exhibit hall and enjoy the
rest of the agilent event today and
tomorrow take care stay healthy bye bye
for now